Hallo!
Ring, ding, ding. Ich bin so aufgeregt,
Manuel. (Ich auch.) Ich glaube, wir sind
jetzt live auf YouTube. Hallo Leute!
Hi. Ja, komisch oder? Ich podcaste
sonst gerne ohne Kamera, aber …
Ja, ist auch viel bequemer, weil
dann muss man sich nicht anziehen,
also keine Klamotten, also, sich nicht
schick machen, ne? Muss nicht duschen,
kann einfach aus dem Bett aufstehen,
wie wir das normalerweise machen.
Aber was tun wir nicht nach 100 Episoden?
Wir haben uns heute richtig vorbereitet für euch,
liebe Zuschauer. Ihr seht jetzt zum ersten Mal,
wie das hier aussieht bei uns. Es
ist Episode Nummer 100. Manuel,
wie sieht es denn bei dir aus? Ist das der
normale Ort, an dem du sonst podcastest?
Nein, normalerweise podcaste
ich in meinem Schrank,
weil ich da einen guten, trockenen Ton
habe und heute bin ich im Wohnzimmer,
was noch etwas kahl ist, deswegen klinge
ich heute vielleicht ein wenig schalliger.
Echo, Echo, Echo, Echo, Echo.
Genau. Und du?
Ja, ich bin an meinem normalen Schreibtisch, aber
normalerweise steht der so und im Hintergrund ist
dann das Fenster. Das heißt, man sieht
mich nicht so gut. Ich habe jetzt heute
extra Licht reingemacht, ne, hier Kabel, so,
schön Licht aufgestellt. Und ich habe meinen
Kleiderschrank in den Hintergrund gemacht,
damit ich kein Licht im Hintergrund habe.
Very nice, very nice. Wir sind
hier voll YouTube plus Podcast.
Profi. Was feiern wir denn heute, Manuel?
Ja, Episode 100, obwohl wir eigentlich schon viel
mehr Episoden gemacht haben. Und das ist
auch eine gute Überleitung, denn ich habe,
ich weiß, du magst gerne Quizze und ich habe
ein kleines Quiz vorbereitet für dich, Cari.
Das finde ich toll.
Wir müssen aber erst mal die Leute
begrüßen. Wir haben einige Leute,
die schon zuschauen. Ich
weiß nicht genau, wie viele.
Es gucken jetzt über tausend Leute zu, oh,
der Chat ist am Durchdrehen. Hallo Leute!
Ich wollte euch gerade fragen, woher ihr kommt,
aber so schnell kann ich gar nicht lesen, wie ihr
schreibt. "Hallo aus Georgien", Indonesien,
Houston, USA. "Tolles Mikrofon", "hallo aus
Trier", "soy de Nicaragua", "hallo aus Vietnam",
wow! Aus der ganzen Welt gucken uns Leute zu,
sogar mitten in der Nacht, schätze ich. In Vietnam
ist es doch jetzt irgendwie ein Uhr oder so, ne?
Ja, das ist toll. Cari, apropos Zahlen,
hier kommt das Quiz. Ich weiß nicht,
wie gut warst du früher in Mathe in der Schule?
Sehr gut, Manuel.
Sehr gut? Okay, das wollen wir jetzt mal
testen: Also, das hier ist unsere Episode 100,
aber streng genommen haben wir schon, ja, 119
Episoden gemacht. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt hier
schon quasi eigentlich Episode 120, denn wir haben
ja zwischendurch diese Zwischendinger gemacht,
diese kurzen Zwischendurch-Episoden, bevor
wir dann auf drei Mal die Woche gewechselt
sind. Und mit dieser ganzen Information darfst
du jetzt mal schätzen, wie viel Material, also,
wenn jemand heute anfangen würde bei Episode 1
und durchhören würde bis Episode 99 mit allen
Episoden dazwischen inklusive Zwischendinger,
wie viele Stunden und Minuten müsste sie hören?
Das ist ganz schön aufregend. Also am Anfang
haben wir ungefähr eine Stunde gepostet, also
ich schätze mal, die ersten fünfzig waren so eine
Stunde, dann haben wir schon mal fünfzig Stunden.
Dann haben wir ja noch die Zwischendinger und die
anderen Sachen, wenn das dann noch mal siebzig
sind mal dreißig, sind das ungefähr fünfunddreißig
Stunden. Sagen wir mal neunzig Stunden Material.
Nicht schlecht, sechsundsiebzig Stunden und
achtundvierzig Minuten. Das
sind knapp über drei Tage.
Wow! Da applaudiere ich mir noch mal selber.
Dann haben wir ja irgendwann angefangen, noch so
eine Aftershow zu machen, wo wir ab und zu noch so
einen Bonus am Ende posten für die Mitglieder.
Was meinst du, wie viel ist das mittlerweile?
Da hast du ja immer alles reingeschnitten,
ne? Ich habe die am Anfang, ich, mittlerweile
höre ich die Aftershow immer und ich habe sogar
gemerkt, unsere Patrons, also unsere Mitglieder,
hören die auch immer bis zum Ende. Das ist
schon manchmal zehn Minuten, fünfzehn Minuten
auch manchmal. Manchmal besprechen wir unsere
Termine und dann haben wir schon ein paar Mal
so einen Test gemacht, um zu gucken, ob die
Leute noch zuhören, während wir unsere Termine
besprechen. Und haben sie tatsächlich. Sagen wir
mal, ungefähr pro Episode fünf mal hundertzwanzig.
Wir haben aber viel später erst angefangen
damit, nicht bei Episode eins, genau.
Ach so, okay. Na dann sagen wir mal zehn Stunden.
Auch sehr gut geschätzt, acht Stunden
mittlerweile. Und jetzt kommt meine letzte Frage,
denn wir haben zu allen Episoden
ein Transkript. Und was schätzt du,
wie viele Wörter sind das insgesamt mittlerweile?
Das habe ich nicht ganz genau ausgerechnet,
aber ungefähr. Du kannst es auch ausdrücken
in Büchern oder in einem bekannten Buch.
Boah, schwierig, ne? Also,
ist es mehr als ein Buch?
Ja.
Vielleicht … Das ist jetzt schwierig,
Manuel. Ich lese doch gar keine Bücher.
Okay, ich sage mal eine Zah…
also soll ich mal sagen in …
Sag mal eine Wörterzahl.
Wörterzahl. Also, wie viele Wörter sprechen
wir denn pro Minute? Sagen wir mal,
pro Minute sprechen wir schon mal vierzig
Wörter, mal sechzig sind zweitausendvierhundert,
mal fünfundsiebzig Stunden. Ich
muss das mal kurz ausrechnen.
Sag mal aus dem Bauch …
Wie viel ist fünfundsiebzig mal
zweitausendvierhundert? Hundertachtzigtausend
Wörter.
Also es sind deutlich mehr, es ist
ungefähr eine halbe Million Wörter
oder ungefähr so viel wie die gesamte
"Herr der Ringe"-Reihe, ohne der Hobbit.
Man, das wollte ich sagen. Ich wollte sagen: Ist
das schon so viel wie die "Herr der Ringe"-Reihe?
(Fast.) Manuel, was mich wundert, ist, dass
Janusz noch gar nicht vorbeigekommen ist.
Wenn es was zu feiern gibt, ist er immer dabei.
Was hast du denn zum Feiern mitgebracht heute?
Wasser.
Ich habe eine Flasche Sekt, die ist noch
von meinen Eltern, die waren zu Besuch,
im Eisfach, haben wir nicht
geschafft. Und ich dachte,
ich mach die mal auf heute zur
Feier des Tages. Was sagst du?
Das ist ja genial, damit habe ich nicht gerechnet.
Janusz! Es gibt ja etwas zu feiern. Und hast du
denn was mitgebracht, vielleicht Luftschlangen?
Nee, nix, tut mir leid. Gar nichts.
Eine Soundmaschine. Oh, guck mal, wer da dabei
ist. Wie Janusz, du bist schon am Feiern?
Nein, am Vorfeiern, glaube ich.
Ja, auf 100 Episoden, Manuel.
Auf 100 Episoden. Prost! Erleben
wir jetzt ein großes Desaster? Wird
jetzt gleich das Schlafzimmer voller Schaum? Nein.
Gott sei Dank nicht. Wir
haben es geschafft. Janusz,
wir beide stoßen jetzt an.
Manuel, das ist für dich.
Hätte ich das ge… ja, Prost, ich
stoße mit Wasser an. Ich weiß,
das macht man nicht in Deutschland, aber …
Ja, das ist alles in Ordnung. Das trinkt Janusz
für dich sozusagen. Also, Janusz trinkt so,
als wärst du jetzt hier und das bist jetzt du
quasi. Janusz, auf den Podcast und auf dich,
Manuel, denn du hast dieses Projekt ja gestartet.
Auf uns alle und auf alle,
die zuhören und zuschauen.
Janusz, man sieht dich gar nicht. Wie geht es
dir denn heute, nach hundert Jahren Podcast?
Ja, ich glaube, ich bin einer der größten Fans.
Janusz hört tatsächlich alle Podcasts.
Ja, und zwar manche zweimal sogar.
Und dann freut er sich immer. Und manchmal
lacht er dann laut im Nebenraum, das ist …
Total. Und ich mag es auch sehr,
anderen Menschen zu erzählen,
wie toll ihr seid, so sehr, dass Manuel
irgendwann sauer geworden ist. Wir haben
seine Freunde getroffen und ich habe da
angefangen, zu erzählen, wie toll ihr seid.
Das ist auch ein bisschen peinlich.
Er sagte so: "Papa, hör jetzt
auf, Sachen zu verkaufen."
Jetzt ist aber gut. Ja,
schön, haben wir angestoßen.
Das ist eigentlich auch eine gute
Überleitung, denn wir wollten ja
zumindest mal kurz darüber sprechen,
warum wir das hier überhaupt machen oder?
Das ist ein gutes Thema.
Das ist unser …
Thema der Woche: Warum wir diesen Podcast machen
Thema der Woche.
Ja, hundert Episoden. Warum machen wir
das überhaupt? Cari, du darfst anfangen.
Ich? Okay. Ich sage dir ganz ehrlich, also
am Anfang habe ich das ja einfach so aus
Spaß ausprobiert. Du hattest Bock auf
das Projekt, ich hatte gar keine Ahnung,
wie das funktioniert mit so einem Podcast, aber
ich dachte, "reden, das kann ich", aber ich,
ganz ehrlich: Meine größte Motivation ist — und
das sehe ich ja auch bei YouTube — ist, dass ganz
viele Menschen Deutsch lernen, nach Deutschland
kommen und dieser Prozess des Lernens und des
Neuseins ist ja auch manchmal schwierig, ne?
Also, generell ist es schon schwierig, im Leben
mit manchen Änderungen klarzukommen. Ich merke das
jetzt wieder im Winter, es wird dunkel draußen,
jetzt haben wir noch Corona, dann kommt so eine
kleine Wintermüdigkeit, wo man denkt, "ach man,
jetzt wieder sechs Monate warten." Und dann freue
ich mich besonders auf meine Lieblingssendungen,
auf meine Podcasts, Fernsehshows und das macht
mir dann gute Laune. Und so eine Laune braucht
man auch, wenn man in ein neues Land
zieht. Man braucht irgendwie Freunde,
die einem helfen dabei und ich hoffe, dass wir so
ein Freund sind und dass wir Menschen ein bisschen
dabei helfen können, die Sprache zu lernen und
sich in Deutschland ein bisschen wohler zu fühlen,
weil hier ist es ja manchmal kalt und dunkel
und manchmal sind die Leute auch unfreundlich.
Und ich hoffe, dass wir den Leuten einfach
ein bisschen bessere Laune machen können.
Das ist total schön und das wollte ich eigentlich
als letztes sagen, aber da schließe ich mich jetzt
einfach an und ich finde das auch so schön,
weil uns oft Leute schreiben, so, "hey,
ihr kennt mich nicht, aber ich habe euch jetzt so
lange zugehört und habe so viel von euch erfahren
über diesen Podcast, dass es sich anfühlt, als
wärt ihr meine Freunde." Und auch, wenn wir den
ganzen Leuten natürlich nicht permanent zuhören,
fühlt sich das so an, als hätten wir durch diesen
Podcast wahnsinnig viele Freunde einfach gewonnen
auf der ganzen Welt. Und das klingt vielleicht ein
bisschen sentimental, weiß ich nicht, aber das ist
für mich auch eine ganz große Freude. Ansonsten
hoffe ich, also beziehungsweise von Anfang an war
meine Hoffnung, dass wir es irgendwie schaffen,
einen Weg zu finden, wie Leute Deutsch
lernen können, entweder ganz aktiv und
so selbstmotiviert, richtig mit hinsetzen und
Transkript lesen und Wörter unterstreichen und
also aktives Lernen, aber eben auch so dieses
passive "ich höre einfach zu und ab und zu hole
ich mal das Handy aus der Tasche und gucke auf
ein Wort oder ab und zu schlage ich mal was nach,
aber ich umgebe mich einfach passiv mit der
Sprache". Und das war meine Hoffnung und ich
glaube, das funktioniert ja ganz gut. Und das dann
eben so zu machen, dass es entertaining genug ist,
also irgendwie spannend und unterhaltsam genug,
dass man auch noch weiterhört, wenn man schon sehr
gut Deutsch spricht, weil das habe ich immer bei
mir selbst gemerkt, dass ich so manche Sachen mir
angehört habe zum Sprachen lernen, die ich dann
aufgehört habe zu hören, als ich die Sprache schon
gut genug konnte. Und das ist meine Hoffnung,
dass wir das noch sehr lange Zeit bieten können.
Danke, Manuel, für deine Ansprache.
Es gibt von meiner Seite einen
Applaus dafür. Hast du sehr schön gesagt,
sehr schön auch, ja, ich sehe das ähnlich. Was
machen wir jetzt, Manuel? Ich bin ganz aufgeregt.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja jetzt, es
wäre jetzt eine gute Gelegenheit,
wo wir schon so viele Leute haben, die
hier dabei sind, dass wir einfach mal
wieder unser bekanntes Segment machen mit
dem schönen Namen … bist du schon bereit?
Ich bin bereit, ja.
Eure Fragen LIVE
Jetzt wird es tatsächlich etwas schwierig.
Wir wollen eure Fragen live hier beantworten,
allerdings ist der Chat so schnell, dass
wir und Isi, Isi ist im Chat und managt
den Chat oder versucht auch ein bisschen zu
moderieren. Isi soll die Fragen raussuchen,
aber es ist so schnell, dass wir kaum
was lesen können. Also wir würden euch
gerne jetzt bitten: Schreibt uns Fragen,
die wir beantworten können hier im Chat,
aber nicht ganz so viele gleichzeitig,
damit wir sie noch lesen können.
Sprecht euch ab, bitte. Einer nach dem anderen.
Schwierig, aber ja, das, wir freuen uns auf
eure Fragen. Ich habe schon eine Einstiegsfrage,
und zwar hat die Natalia auf Patreon
gepostet und damit wollte ich mal anfangen,
das finde ich nämlich persönlich
sehr interessant. Sie schreibt:
"Seid ihr introvertiert oder
extrovertiert?" Du darfst anfangen.
Eine sehr gute Frage. Also, ich
glaube, ich bin schon extrovertiert,
weil ich gerne auf Leute zugehe und gerne,
weiß ich nicht. Ich bin schon extrovertiert,
aber ich habe da so ein bestimmtes Limit, also
ich kann nur eine Zeit lang extrovertiert sein
und danach brauche ich ganz viel Zeit für mich
selbst, aber ich glaube, wenn wir jetzt nur in
diesem … Wir haben ja witzigerweise gerade
viel über Labels gesprochen und Kategorien
und ich habe auch ein Label benutzt und viel
Feedback bekommen, dass das kein gutes Label ist.
Mehrere Labels hast du benutzt.
Genau und deswegen, ja, aber wenn ich
mich entscheiden müsste, würde ich sagen,
ich bin extrovertiert und genieße
es, Zeit für mich selbst zu haben.
Ja. Ich muss sagen, es gibt ja häufig ein
Missverständnis zwischen … extrovertiert sind
Leute, die gerne viel reden und introvertiert
sind Leute, die gerne wenig reden. Und es ist
ja aber auch so, dass es darum geht, was dir gut
tut. Zum Beispiel extrovertiert heißt ja auch,
dass du Leute um dich herum brauchst, um
dich gut zu fühlen. Introvertiert heißt eher,
dass du viel Ruhe brauchst, um dich gut zu fühlen.
Und bei den gängigen Persönlichkeitstests, die man
so machen kann, bin ich tatsächlich in der Mitte.
Ich bin sechzig Prozent extrovertiert, vierzig
Prozent introvertiert und das heißt bei mir,
ich brauche immer Leute jede Woche. Wenn ich zum
Beispiel sieben Tage keine Mensch, keinen Menschen
sehe, dann fühle ich mich, als wäre ich nicht
vollständig, so. Ich brauche dann den menschlichen
Kontakt, um mich gut zu fühlen und auch irgendwie
aufzugehen und eine Rolle zu haben. Wenn ich
jedoch jeden Abend Menschen sehe, dann habe
ich nicht genug Ruhe. Also ich muss tatsächlich
und ich habe mir selber eine Regel gemacht. Meine
Regel ist: Drei Tage die Woche will ich abends
rausgehen oder Leute treffen. Das ist natürlich
jetzt mit der Corona-Situation schwierig, aber
dann verabrede ich mich zum Beispiel zum Spielen
oder zum Telefonieren. Und vier Tage die Woche
bin ich zu Hause, das ist so ungefähr mein Maß.
Ja, ja, interessant. Ich glaube,
nach dieser Maßgabe bin ich sogar noch
ein bisschen weniger extrovertiert als du.
Stimmt, du kannst gut alleine sein, ne?
Mir reicht einmal pro Woche.
Cool, dann haben wir einige
andere Fragen bekommen. Manuel,
möchtest du dir eine erste Frage aussuchen?
Sehr gerne. Vielen Dank an Isi, dass du
das so ein bisschen sortierst hier. Und
ich, wir fangen mal an mit einer einfachen
Frage: "Was sind eure Lieblingslieder?"
Ganz einfach.
Das wechselt bei mir sehr oft, aber eins meiner
absoluten Lieblingslieder seit einigen
Jahren ist "Her Mercy" von Glen Hansard.
Ich kann gar nicht ein Lieblingslied
so schnell benennen, aber ich kann
eine Lieblingsband benennen.
Meine absolute Lieblingsband
heißt Django Django. Kennst du die? Hast
du schon, habe ich dir schon geschickt.
Schon öfter bei dir auch gehört.
Und ich war mal mit Isi auf einem Konzert, liebe
Isi, die hört ja zu und liest gerade den Chat,
das war so schön und wenn wir das
noch mal wiederholen könnten nach
der Corona-Pandemie, das wäre mein größter Wunsch.
Okay, dann bist du dran.
Genau, ich, meine nächste Frage ist
von Adruna: "Weiß jemand von euch,
aus welcher Region Manuels und Caris
deutsche Aussprache kommt?" Manuel,
deine Aussprache ist sehr genau
und sehr deutlich. Woher kommst du?
Das kommt von deinem harten Training,
dass ich deutlich sprechen soll.
Hach, schön.
Nein, wir sind beide in
Münster in Westfalen geboren,
das ist in Westdeutschland, in … oder man
sollte sagen im Westen von Deutschland,
in der Nähe von den Niederlanden und
da spricht man so, wie wir sprechen.
Richtig. Also relativ, keinen starken Akzent
oder keinen starken Dialekt, kann man sagen.
Man redet überhaupt in Norddeutschland sehr viel
Hochdeutsch. Was ist deine nächste Lieblingsfrage?
Louise fragt: "Was ist das Schwierigste, wenn wir
den Podcast produzier… am Podcast produzieren?"
Also ich würde sagen, das Zeitaufwendigste, wo
wir auch mittlerweile einiges an Hilfe haben,
ist das Transkribieren für das Transkript und
die Vokabeln aufzubereiten zum Lernen. Und vom,
das Pod… am Podcasten selbst finde ich am
schwierigsten, dass wir uns kurz fassen,
weil manchmal könnten wir ewig lange reden.
Das stimmt. Das ist manchmal stressig,
ja, aber macht nichts. Daniel schreibt:
"Hallo Manuel und Cari, ich habe noch eine
Frage, sage ich mal. Sonnst du dich gerne nackt,
wie viele Deutsche(n)? Es wäre interessant,
über dieses Thema zu reden." Das ist ein
interessantes Thema. Die deutsche FKK-Kultur
und … (Freikörperkultur.) Viele Leute denken ja,
dass das alle Deutschen so machen. Manuel,
warst du schon mal im (am) FKK-Strand?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, nee. Ich
bin aber generell kein Strandtyp,
also ich halte es immer nur so zwei Stunden aus
und ich bin nicht so ein Strandtyp tatsächlich.
Oder liegst du manchmal nackt auf dem Balkon?
Intime Frage, aber wenn man es öffentlich macht …
Auch nicht, ist auch zu kalt im Moment.
Da gab es ja dieses berühmte Bild von dem Typen,
der am Teufelsee diese Sau ver… also diese Wild,
das Wildschwein verfolgt hat, nackt, weil das
Wildschwein seinen Laptop geklaut hat. Es ist
ein deutsches Ding, aber man muss sagen, es
ist auch in Deutschland eine eigene Kultur,
also es gibt ja, wie in allen Ländern gibt es
verschiedene Gruppen, verschiedene Kulturen.
Und nicht alle Menschen in Deutschland machen das
oder sind daran gewöhnt. Und manche Familien sind
so aufgewachsen, dass sie immer nackt am Strand
sind und andere Familien sind so aufgewachsen,
dass sie immer Kleidung tragen. Und für mich ist
es zum Beispiel so, dass ich nie irgendwo nackt
war und deswegen finde ich das auch komisch,
aber ich weiß, dass es das gibt und ich weiß,
dass das viele Leute toll finden. Und
das ist ein interessantes Phänomen.
Ja, spannend. Du hast die Frage übrigens nicht
beantwortet, Cari, finde ich nicht in Ordnung.
Doch, ich habe doch gesagt,
ich mache das auch nie, ich habe das doch … in
unserer Familie wurde das nicht gemacht, ja.
Okay, gut, ja. "Als du ein Kind warst",
fragt Tran, wenn ich das richtig sehe,
"was wolltet ihr beruflich
machen, als ihr Kinder wart?"
Spannend. Ich habe, ich habe
noch eine Liste von damals,
du auch? Habe ich irgendwann wiedergefunden.
Also ich weiß, dass ich zur Grundschullehrerin
mal gesagt habe, dass ich gerne arbeitslos sein
möchte. Ich glaube, ich war damals
nicht so motiviert. Ich weiß aber,
dass ich früh angefangen habe, auch durch Janusz,
Videos zu machen. Und meine Mutter hat
auch sehr früh eine Videokamera gehabt,
damit habe ich viel gefilmt. Also eigentlich
habe ich schon sehr lange Medien gemacht.
Interessant. Das war
tatsächlich nicht mein Wunsch,
also ganz früher als Kind hatte ich
aufgeschrieben, glaube ich, Pilotin.
Ja, wollte ich auch mal machen, ging
aber nicht wegen Rot-Grün-Schwäche.
Pilotin und Formel eins-Fahrerin, also, auf jeden
Fall was mit Action, wo ich am Steuer sitze. Aber
guck mal, ich, Tran hat noch geschrieben: "Was
wäre, wenn ihr keine Videos produzieren würdet?"
Dann nur noch Podcast, sieben Tage die Woche.
Schön. Matt hat geschrieben, das finde ich sehr
interessant: "Was ist für euch der schwierigste
englische Akzent zum Verstehen? Ich komme aus
den USA und bin neugierig, was die Deutschen
darüber denken." Welche Akzente kannst du
nicht gut verstehen? Britisch, Australisch,
dann gibt es noch, ganz, ja, dann gibt es noch, in
den USA gibt es ganz viele verschiedene Akzente.
Ich würde mal so sagen, so schottisch und so,
ne? (Stimmt.) Oder vielleicht auch,
ich war mal in der Karibik, so auf …
Du warst in der Karibik?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
wo das war … Isla Mujeres.
Trinke ich noch mal einen Schluck.
Ja, als ich in Mexiko gelebt habe. Und dort wird
zum Teil Englisch gesprochen mit einem
Akzent, der sehr, sehr schwierig ist.
Das ist dann ja teilweise schon eine Kreolsprache,
wenn das aus dem Englischen entstanden ist,
aber auch andere Wörter aus anderen
Sprachen, ne? Ja, ich finde, glaube ich,
auch Schottisch und Irisch am schwierigsten.
Ich weiß, dass ich mal mit jemandem aus Kansas
City in einem Hostel war und dass ich da
sehr schwer, dass ich das sehr schwer fand,
den zu verstehen. Ich glaube, sonst in den USA
verstehe ich, ich verstehe Amerikaner generell
besser als Briten, muss ich sagen. Und Australier,
habe ich letztens zum ersten Mal gemerkt,
hören sich für mich auch an die Briten. Ich habe
nämlich eine Serie geguckt auf Netflix und erst
nach zwei Staffeln gemerkt, dass die gar nicht
in Großbritannien, sondern in Australien spielt.
Musst du aufs "mate" achten. Cari, Raphael
möchte gerne ein Bewerbungsinterview mit
uns machen scheinbar und fragt:
"Wo seht ihr euch in fünf Jahren?"
Ja, Manuel, da du darfst du mal anfangen.
An der Spitze der YouTube-Charts.
Und der deutschen Podcast-Charts.
Genau. Nee, keine Ahnung, also, ich bin totaler
Fan von short-term goals, so kurzfristige Ziele,
wo man dann sich voll darauf fokussiert und
immer so ein Jahr vielleicht in die Zukunft
gucken und ansonsten einfach vertrauen,
dass es schon alles funktionieren wird.
Ich habe wirklich kein Ziel, so in
fünf Jahren, wo ich gerne sein möchte.
Muss ich sagen, habe ich auch nicht so direkt,
also, ich möchte gerne, dass sich unser Projekt
entwickelt. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn es Easy
Languages in allen Sprachen gäbe, wenn wir auch so
seltene Sprachen oder kleinere Sprachen vielleicht
produzieren würden, das würde mich auch freuen,
wenn wir einfach mehr Partner hätten, aber ich
habe jetzt kein Ziel. Ich möchte auf jeden Fall,
für mich selber persönlich möchte ich, dass ich
mich weiterentwickelt habe, dass ich gelernt habe,
wenn ich zurückgucke, dass ich sehe, ich
bin nicht mehr die Cari von vor fünf Jahren,
aber ich glaube, das wird schon passieren.
Wichtige Frage von HirschintheWoods:
"Habt ihr auch im echten Leben immer
so gute Laune? Wie macht ihr das?"
Also ich muss wirklich sagen, Cari, das
bewundere ich auch an dir. Das, finde ich,
ist auch eine gewisse Professionalität, dass
du sagen kannst: Jetzt sind wir auf Sendung
und jetzt bin ich auch gut drauf. Also
ich weiß, wir hatten so ein paar Momente,
zum Beispiel am Anfang des Podcasts, wo wir
mal eine Stunde aufgenommen haben und dann
gab es ein technisches Problem und dann war die
Stunde einfach weg und dann war die Stimmung
erst mal so ziemlich down. Und dann hast du
gesagt, so, genau. Und dann hast du gesagt:
"Wir machen uns jetzt aber gute Laune
und wir starten jetzt noch mal durch."
Hast du das nicht gesagt?
Ich meine, du wärst das gewesen,
aber jedenfalls, nee, also ich,
also ich persönlich habe auch schlechte
Tage. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht?
Warte mal kurz, Manuel.
Okay, was diejenigen, die nicht auf
YouTube schauen, sondern das später im
Podcast-Feed hören, jetzt nicht gesehen
haben, ist, dass Cari Pantomime macht.
Richtig, ich bin eine Pantomime-Meisterin.
Ja, ich habe nicht immer so gute Laune,
muss ich sagen. Heute hatte ich
auch mal schlechte Laune, wer …
Heute sogar?
Ja, heute hatte ich schon schlechte Laune,
aber ich muss sagen, dass ich das immer
ändern muss. Also wenn ich irgendwo schlechte
Laune sehe bei anderen Menschen oder bei mir,
ich kann das so nicht so lange aushalten. Ich
will dann gerne, ja, will dann gerne weitermachen,
will gerne darüber reden, bis wir das Problem
gelöst haben. Und gute Laune ist für mich,
das gehört zum Programm und das ist auch für mich
der Sinn dieser Show. Oh, die Frage interessiert
mich, Manuel. Lucy schreibt: "Manuel, hat 'Wer
wird Millionär?' dich als Person verändert?"
Oh, das weiß ich nicht, das müsstest du ja sagen.
Habe ich mich verändert seit "Wer
wird Millionär?" Ich glaube nicht.
Nee, du hast jetzt bisher
nicht so viele Sachen … Nee,
du hast mit deinem Reichtum nicht
um dich geschmissen und das gezeigt.
Ich habe mir einen Fernseher gekauft,
das ist mein erster Fernseher in meinem
Leben. Das ist schon … (Und eine
Couch.) ein großer Sch… Ja gut,
eine Couch auch. Nee, ach, ich weiß, ich hoffe
nicht, also, wenn Geld einen sehr verändert,
dann ist das ja schade meistens, also ich hoffe,
dass, dass dieser Gewinn mich nicht verändert hat.
Nee, kann ich auch nicht bestätigen. Dann
haben wir noch hier, Al Hamsa schreibt:
"Warum macht ihr den Podcast nicht auf Englisch?"
Isi sagt dazu im Hintergrund: "Es gibt bald auch
den Podcast in anderen Sprachen, zum Beispiel bei
Easy English." Wenn ihr Englisch lernen wollt,
geht mal zu Easy English bei YouTube
und hoffentlich bald auch als Podcast.
Da freue ich mich schon drauf, eventuell
auch von anderen Sprachen. Cari,
welche Eigenschaft hättest du gerne? Fragt …
Schwierig. Oh, da ruft gerade
ein Freund an. Soll ich da …
Ja, geht ran, klar, ist wie immer hier.
Das ist schwierig, das ist ja sehr persönlich,
ne? Welche Eigenschaft … oder soll ich bei was,
irgendwas … also ich wäre natürlich gerne
manchmal noch ein bisschen unemotionaler.
Ich … manchmal nehme ich Sachen sehr emotional
auf und ich möchte gern noch besser sein so im
Vermitteln, das ist, da ist es immer gut,
wenn man unemotional ist. Ansonsten wäre
natürlich auch cool, eine Eigenschaft so wie in
die Zukunft gucken. Wäre hilfreich auf jeden Fall.
Ja. Ich merke auch gerade, dass wir da schon mal
drüber gesprochen haben. Ich hatte ein Déjà-vu
jetzt gerade. Ich weiß allerdings nicht mehr, was
ich damals gesagt habe, aber ich würde auch nicht
gerne weniger emotional sein, aber die Eigenschaft
entwickeln oder die Fähigkeit entwickeln, meine
Emotionen noch besser von außen zu beobachten,
also zu merken, oh, jetzt bin ich gerade traurig
oder glücklich oder genervt oder was auch
immer, aber da arbeite ich auch schon dran, ja.
Wie macht man das? Mit Meditation?
Ja, zum Beispiel, das ist
eins der Ziele von Meditation.
Lecker.
"Cari, würdest du dich als ordentlich oder
unordentlich bezeichnen?", fragt Braydon.
Sehr ordentlich. Also eher ordentlich, muss
man sagen, aber jetzt in der Wohnung merke
ich doch schon, in der neuen Wohnung, ich bin
eher ordentlich. Janusz ist eher das Gegenteil,
du bist auch eher ordentlich, würde
ich mal so einfach von dir behaupten,
sehr ordentlich sogar. (Definitiv.) Und ich finde,
das ist immer ein sehr interessanter Kulturclash,
wenn Janusz dann … Also jetzt zum
Beispiel letztens beim Umzug, ne,
als wir den Keller ausmisten mussten — das
ist ein schöner Satz, den Keller ausmisten
mussten. Also wir wollten die alten Sachen
wegschmeißen, aber Janusz mag es, alles zu
sammeln und ich mag es einfach, dass alles, dass
es nicht so viel gibt und alles gut geordnet ist.
Ja, geht mir genauso. Ich mag
es gerne ordentlich und sauber.
Das ist eine lange Frage, die haben wir
aber schon mal gesprochen, ne? Wie bist
du eigentlich auf die Idee
gekommen mit dem Podcast?
Das haben wir wahrscheinlich
ganz am Anfang mal besprochen.
Müsst ihr den Podcast noch mal von vorne hören.
Gab es da keinen "aha"-Moment, wo du dachtest …
du standest im Dschungel irgendwie in Costa Rica
und dachtest: "Das ist es."
Ich glaube, ich höre schon seit so vielen Jahren
Podcasts, dass ich irgendwann immer dachte,
ich möchte mitmachen und dann bei Easy
German dachte ich einfach irgendwie,
das könnte doch hilfreich sein. Es gab
nicht so einen Moment, aber ich weiß,
dass ich lange darüber geredet habe, bis wir
es dann endlich gemacht haben. Ja. Savas fragt:
"Was ist unsere Lieblingsepisode
vom Podcast?" Hast du eine?
Ich hatte immer eine, aber jetzt habe ich es
vergessen, na, wenn man nicht direkt darauf kommt,
ist das schwierig, ne? Janusz sagt immer, die
Episode mit der Soundmaschine ist die beste,
deswegen habe ich die heute noch mal mitgebracht,
weil, ja, weiß ich auch nicht. Hast du eine?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich so … ich glaube,
ich habe manchmal so Episoden, wo ich denke,
so, "die ist irgendwie nicht so gut geworden",
aber ganz oft denke ich so, "das, die war rund,
die Episode", da haben wir es geschafft,
eine gute Balance zu finden zwischen,
weiß ich nicht, es hat Spaß gemacht, wir
waren gut drauf und wir haben trotzdem
auch irgendetwas vermittelt oder
über irgendein Thema gesprochen.
Es muss eine gute Mischung sein aus Fun, Fun
und Lernen und auch ernsten Themen. Wir haben
ja manchmal immer eine gute Mischung aus ernsten
Themen. Manchmal haben wir zu viel ernste Themen,
manchmal zu viel … nee, zu viel Fun kann es
nicht geben. Apropos Fun, sollen wir Janusz
noch mal zum Ende einladen für das große Finale?
(Auf jeden Fall.) Janusz, falls du uns gerade
zuhörst hier live bei YouTube, komm mal
vorbei. Hier steht die Tür offen für dich,
wir freuen uns, wenn du wieder auftauchst. Ist
jetzt auch ein Test, um zu hören, ob Janusz …
Ob er überhaupt noch zuhört.
Ob Janusz noch da ist.
Ich suche mal eine gute Frage
für ihn. Also hier geht es auf
jeden Fall ums Gitarre spielen,
das wird Janusz interessieren.
Ja, sind gar nicht mehr so viele Fragen,
die wir haben. Oh, aber im Live Chat,
da geht es rund. Rundikowski, viele Fragen
hier dabei. Das kann man gar nicht so schnell …
Oh ja, das geht echt ab, ja. Ja,
ich glaube, er hat abgeschaltet.
Janusz? Ich ruf mal rüber, warte.
Ich beantworte währenddessen noch eine Frage.
Hier fragt jemand, dass ich mal gesagt habe,
dass ich Minimalist bin und das erklären
soll. Das ist wirklich eine gute Frage,
weil ich glaube nämlich, mittlerweile bin ich
vielleicht nicht mehr so minimalistisch wie
früher, als ich nur einen Rucksack hatte
mit Sachen und damit auf Weltreise war.
Bin da. Natürlich habe ich nicht abgeschaltet.
Ja, jedenfalls finde ich es minimalistisch, wenn
man nur die Sachen hat, die einem wirklich Freude
bringen oder die man wirklich haben will. Das
ist schwer zu erklären, aber es heißt nicht,
dass man nicht auch mehr haben kann
als das, was man zum Überleben braucht,
aber eben nicht Dinge anhäufen, wo man sich
irgendwann fragt, warum habe ich das eigentlich?
Apropos Geld, da kommt jetzt
eine Frage, ganz wichtig:
"Du warst auf Weltreise,
was kostet das eigentlich?"
Da wollte ich schon sehr lange mal einen Blogpost
zu schreiben, bin ich nie zu gekommen. Es kommt
sehr darauf an, wie man reist und so weiter,
aber es gibt ein gutes Buch, das heißt "How to
travel (around) the world on 50 dollars or less
per day" und das ist ein ganz guter Richtwert,
also man kann relativ komfortabel reisen für
fünfzig Dollar am Tag, wenn man flexibel ist
und eine gute Mischung hat aus nicht so
teuren Ländern und sehr teuren Ländern.
Fünfzig Dollar am Tag, sagst
du, das geht? Mit Unterkunft?
Das geht. Mit allem, mit allen
Ausgaben, die man so hat.
Inkludiert das dann zelten oder wie machst du das?
Nee, dafür muss man nicht zelten. Ich glaube,
da kann man schon in einem Bett
für schlafen in vielen Orten.
Ja, nicht schlecht. Ja, dann haben wir hier
noch eine Frage von Zagg. Er möchte wissen,
er weiß, dass Janusz gerne Gitarre spielt
und aber fragt, ob auch andere von uns ein
Instrument spielen. Und wenn wir eine Easy
German-Band hätten, wer würde was spielen?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Was
würdest du denn spielen, Cari?
Ich würde gerne, ich kann das aber nicht,
ich würde gerne Schlagzeug spielen.
Ist leider schon besetzt von mir.
Ah, du willst Schlagzeug spielen? Dann nehme
ich die Synthesizer, dann mache ich die …
Oh ja. Sehr geil, sehr geil. Isi,
schreib mal rein, was du machen würdest.
Ja, Isi, was würdest du spielen? Würdest, würde,
Isi würde, vielleicht will sie die Bassgitarre
spielen? Also, einer muss ja auch noch singen,
ne? Das wäre ja auch noch die Frage. (Genau,
wer singt?) Janusz, willst du singen?
Nein, absolut nicht, aber du
musst singen, weil ich glaube,
du bist der beste Sänger von uns
allen, und zwar ohne Vergleich, ja?
Manuel?
Okay, also Isi schreibt, sie möchte Ukulele
spielen. Das wird eine gute Band: Schlagzeug,
Jazzgitarre, Ukulele, Synthesizer und kein Sänger.
Ja, das brauchen wir nicht. Wir sind
eine Instrumentalband. Janusz, möchtest
du zum Abschied noch mal etwas zu unseren
Zuschauern fragen, äh, sagen? Du siehst,
das ist der Chat mit unseren Antworten. Wir
gucken gerade mal hier auf YouTube rein, 1700
Leute gucken zu. Was ist deine Nachricht, wenn
du jetzt eine Nachricht an die Welt geben kannst?
Leute, habt so viel Spaß
im Leben, wie es nur geht.
Ja, das das waren Januszs weise
Worte zum Abschied im Podcast hier.
Noch weisere Worte gibt es dann demnächst
wieder bei "Janusz philosophiert" von ihm.
Ja, müssen wir mal wieder machen, Manuel.
Ja. Cari, ich freue mich auf weitere
zehntausend Episoden. Hundert wäre ja
viel zu wenig. Die haben wir
ja schon in ein paar Wochen.
Richtig. Zehntausende, machen wir noch. Wolltest
du noch was sagen vielleicht zum Abschied? Zum
Beispiel, wo kommt diese Episode eigentlich als
Podcast raus? Wie (be)kommt man an das Transkript?
Genau, gute Fragen. Also vielleicht hören uns
ja Leute zu, die noch gar nicht den Podcast
so regulär abonniert haben. Also, einen
Podcast findet man in jeder Podcast-App,
da könnt ihr euch eine App aussuchen.
Und alle Infos gibt es auch auf unserer
Webseite easygerman.fm und unsere Mitglieder
auf Patreon, die bekommen zu jeder Episode ein
Transkript und eine Vokabelhilfe, wo man
dann die Wörter mit Übersetzungen sieht
und Bonusmaterial. Genau, das wären
eigentlich so die wichtigsten Punkte.
Und wenn ihr ein Mitglied seid, dann
bekommen Manuel und ich tatsächlich eure
Nachrichten. Ich zeige das jetzt
nicht an aus Datenschutzgründen,
aber ich habe gerade … und natürlich aus
Lichtgründen, wie man sieht. Ich habe gerade,
ich bekomme hier die ganze Zeit Live-Updates
aus Patreon, was die Leute schreiben. Henrique
hat zum Beispiel gerade einen, auch eine
Frage geschickt auf Patreon und schreibt:
"Liebe Grüße aus Brasilien, ihr seid super! Ich
möchte gerne wissen, was denkt ihr über Manfred
Mey, über den Wolken?" Ist tatsächlich
ein Song, den ich gespielt habe auf …
Wie hast du den genannt? Reinhard Mey heißt er.
Ja, Manfred Mey hat der geschrieben.
Den gibt es, glaube ich, nicht.
"Über den Wolken" ist auf jeden Fall ein
bekannter klassischer Song in Deutschland,
den ich schon geschrieben habe … nicht
geschrieben, gespielt, ich habe den selber
geschrieben mit zehn. Den habe ich gespielt,
als wir so zehn, zwölf Jahre alt waren,
da hatten wir nämlich eine Band. Isi, Anne —
unsere Freundin, Nachbarin Anne — und ich. Ich
weiß nicht, ob Isi sich noch erinnert, aber wir
haben diesen Song gespielt und es war ziemlich
cheesy. "Über den Wolken …" und dann haben die
anderen im Hintergrund gesungen: "Ay ay ay."
Ja, Reinhard Mey ist ein toller
Liedermacher, auch über diese,
diesen Song hinaus. Haben wir auch letztens
schon mal einen empfohlen im Podcast.
Schreibt gerade Henrique: "Es ist Reinhard.
Hahaha." Guck mal, so schnell geht das als Patron.
So schnell geht das. Ihr werdet
direkt berichtigt von uns.
Als Patron seid ihr direkt live dabei
und wir freuen uns auf jeden Fall,
wenn ihr ein Mitglied werdet, denn dann
macht ihr diesen Podcast tatsächlich auch
möglich und bekommt jede Woche, nee, jede
Episode, alle drei Tage, alle zwei Tage,
ein Transkript auch zu der Episode. Manuel,
es hat mich sehr gefreut. Ich finde es toll,
wie wir heute hier gefeiert haben. Marta schreibt
noch: "Grüße aus Pankow. Ich wohne um die Ecke von
eurem Büro und habe euch beim Vorbeigehen
entdeckt." So klein ist die Welt, Marta.
So klein ist Berlin. Ja, schön, also wir hören
uns bald wieder im Podcast und vielleicht
bald mal wieder in einem Livestream,
obwohl das ganz schön aufregend war.
Das schaffen wir. Ich, wir feiern
jetzt weiter, Janusz und ich. Prost!
Bis bald.
Tschüss. (Ciao.)
Tschüss.